check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
dear friends i was reading my book and
then came
a gentleman this handsome gentleman
what's your name tony tony how are you
doing cheers me and you had a nice
discussion
yeah remember uh two weeks ago from
three weeks ago and then i went home
yeah and guess
what what the mic wasn't recording and i
was devastated wow speechless
yeah it goes exactly so yes so anyways
you're here today
you said you wanted to ask me a question
yeah i'm interested in what the quran's
view is on hell
hell yeah i'm hearing from different
muslims
cheers i'm hearing from some muslims
that the position is
that it's possible to be condemned to
hell forever
and from other muslims that that's
metaphorical
and that nobody ends up in hell forever
so i'm asking what
your understanding is okay the orthodox
position
is that um there is going to be people
who will end up in hell forever
there are going to be muslims who are
going to be in health not forever
there are the munafi kun the
disbelievers are going to be in the
lowest part of the hellfire
and they're going to get the most
severest punishment right um there are
people
who allah has mentioned specifically
that they are in hellfire forever
so our position in islam about hellfire
is
the following if you die upon
this belief we will say your origin
yeah your original position is that you
died on disbelief
however can i say that you go in
hellfire
no so let me make this clear for you
again
when you die if we for example we will
say
you will not be buried with the muslims
because you died as a disbeliever
your original position by default is you
died as a disbeliever
if i pass away my original position or
passing away
is as a muslim no one can come and say
ali tawa
was doing dawa for so many years and he
made so many people come to
accept islam which is not true by the
way but i was amazing person whatever it
may be
no one can say i'm going heaven no one
can say you're going hell
okay my my concern is that your view of
allah
is that he would condemn some of his
creation
to eternal hell a lot of his creation
thank you that was very
clear yeah a lot of his creation now now
do you understand that for a lot of
people who aren't muslims
that's a particular sticking point no it
won't be because i've got a little
one i am one of them i've got a little
gift for you
and this gift that allah god almighty
has given to all human beings
is the following and no other religion
has this not christianity not buddhism
not hinduism not sikhism
not christianity not judaism yeah here's
the following
the prophet peace be upon him told us
and allah says in the quran we do not
punish
any nation until we send the messenger
so let's make this clear god almighty
saying we will never
punish any nation until a messenger has
gone there
and told them clear cut that the true
way
is the way of god i understand so so
therefore
in islam islam is the only religion that
says the following listen carefully
if anybody there's four people a child
who hasn't
reached the age of puberty a person who
is insane
the mental uh a person who hasn't
heard the message of islam sure and some
scholars even say
a person who's heard the message of
islam but in a distorted way
terrorism yeah i get it okay so so what
we are told these people will be tested
on the day of judgment
because allah will be we believe god
almighty the most merciful
very merciful okay with respect i think
i understand where you're coming
okay i like the fact that you don't want
to preemptively judge people who've got
mental problems or who haven't heard the
word
people will end up in hell forever
forever and i am
lightly expressing that that creates
concern for some of us and some muslims
did i answer that question you did but
you know you were clear enough to give
me a clear answer allah does do that
i'm hoping you can understand why no no
i'll let us do that
because you know what's interesting
before i was coming here on the phone i
was in mohammad hijab
i want to explain this to you when allah
talks about hellfire
allah says that the hellfire is
something that they earned
when allah talks about paradise he says
it is something that they inherited
i get it
a lot of us feel that you'll hear this
voiced a lot a lot of us feel that
infinite punishment for a finite
transgression
is a disproportionate level no it's not
so if you've gone he goes to hell for a
while and then he comes out
he might have gone finite punishment for
finite transgression
particularly since god created you to be
fallible
but because god seems to have gone i'm
going to build you fallible you're going
to get some things wrong and if you get
certain things wrong i'm going to punish
you infinitely
a lot of us can't gel that with the idea
that he's okay
okay let me let me explain that to you
so here is a misunderstanding
of who allah is yeah the question is the
following
we live a finite life why would we be
destined to hell fire forever
that's the question that was thank you
okay so the question is
we live a finite life why would god put
us in hell forever when we live
we're infallible people let me explain
to you yeah
let's suppose arguments say for every
day
of disobedience to god you deserve one
day in hellfire
okay would you say that is fair it's
fairer fairer okay
all right now if you live 50 years
yeah and 50 years in hell fire that's
fair
okay if god knows that through the rest
of your life if you live the billion
trillion years
you're going to be doing the same thing
again and point it to hellfire is that
just
you know what now let me be clear what
i'm going to say now
because i don't want you to write this
up ali dawa converts stupid atheists
okay i think i'm very intelligent but i
enjoyed
talking i've never heard that argument
before
and that does go some way i don't
believe i don't think it's the case
i've never heard that argument before
and it would go some way to resolving it
yeah i don't you you shifted me ten
percent okay tony so what i would say is
look my job here
is to have a nice similar discussion
yeah we learn from each other i listen
to you sometimes i learn from you
the concept of islam this imagination of
god
almighty is this monster who wants
everyone to go hellfire is not islam
in islam allah wants paradise i hope so
he does you know why because he's the
most merciful let me tell you something
islam when you smile this charity you
get reward look you guys have got a lot
of great things no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no but why don't you come in i know a
lot about islam i think it's true
thank you but what i'm saying tony hear
this out here god almighty has created
us
and he wants paradise for us he does not
want
anyone to go hellfire let that be very
clear the god that we worship
is not god that's saying oh who can i
throw in hell fire
this is not allah in the quran every
single chapter except surat
allah says the most merciful the very
merciful god almighty tells us
his mercy is in hundred forms
only one of them is in this earth yeah
and 99 is even in the hereafter yeah so
the question is this
that god does good one he'll fight for
us no he's
created you he wants you to acknowledge
him worship him and he wants
paradise is not something you earn
paradise is something given to you
so okay oh that's a whole new listen if
you've got to go that's a whole new
difference i thought you earned it
the whole premise of religion is that
you're responsible for your moral choice
paradise is something rewarded so the
default is paradise it's not
yes it's rewarded to you okay it's not
something you earn because unless you
unless you screw up you go to heaven no
no no
if you really screw up when i mean
really i'm talking about really
better if you're going to help forever
yeah but but god almighty has given you
vast options to worship
vast options to uh worship him and the
doors of paradise
are there and there is a big chance for
you to enter in paradise if you don't
and that's your fault okay
listen last words no that was great
thank you
it's a pleasure yeah and i hope we can
do this we always love yes 100
determinism we need to do this yeah it's
hard to turn to termination yeah okay
thank you thank you sorry so guys as you
can see today as around corner
we had a beautiful discussion with tony
i actually had a really nice discussion
with him a couple of weeks ago but there
was no audio
but i said we've got a new camera man
he's making things happen you see that
crisp
camera as you can see bros assistant so
like subscribe share whatever you guys
want to do in charlotte yes
take care